[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: Good afternoon.
So we spent our last
lecture laying out
some of the basic foundations,
making a couple of definitions.
I want to quickly recap
the most important concepts
and definitions.
And then, let me
be blunt, I kind of
want to get through
these definitions, which
I think it's important
to do them precisely,
but there's nothing
significantly challenging
about them.
We just need to make sure they
are defined very precisely.
So now that you've kind of
seen the style of these things,
I would like to sort of
move through the next batch
of these definitions
quickly enough
that we can start to move into
more interesting material.
So a quick recap--
and my apologies,
my daughter has
some kind of a virus that I am
desperately trying to make sure
I do not catch.
And so I will be hydrating
during this lecture.
So I just want to recap some of
the most important concepts we
went over.
So this whole class
is essentially
a study in spacetime.
Later, we're going to
connect spacetime to gravity.
And general relativity
is going to become
the relativistic
theory of gravity.
So we began with a fairly
mathematical definition.
Spacetime is a
manifold of events
that is endowed with a metric.
Manifold, for our
purposes, is essentially
just a set in
which we understand
how different members of the
set are connected to each other.
Events are really just when
and where something happens.
We haven't precisely
defined metric yet.
We will soon.
But intuitively, just
regard it as some kind
of a mathematical object that
gives me a notion of distance
between these events.
I tried and I will
continue to try
to be very careful
to make a distinction
between geometric
objects that live
in the manifold, the
events themselves
with things like a
displacement vector between two
events, other
vectors, which I will
recap the definition
of in just a moment.
They have an existence and
sort of a reality to them
that is deeper and
more fundamental
than the representation
of that object.
So when I say that the
displacement vector is delta t,
delta x, delta y, delta z, that
is according to observer O.
And when I write that down--
I will be very careful
as much as possible.
I will occasionally
screw this up--
but I will try to
write this down
without using an equal sign.
Equal sign implies
a degree of reality
that I do not want to impart
to that representation.
So an equal dot with
a little o here,
that's my personal
notation for delta
x is represented
by these components
according to observer O. And for
shorthand, I was sometimes just
write this by the collection
of indices delta x alpha.
A different observer
O bar, they will
represent this this factor
using the exact same geometric
object.
They all agree that it's
this displacement between two
physical events in spacetime.
But they assign different
coordinates to it.
They give a different
representation to it.
And we find that representation
using a Lorenz transformation.
And I'm not going to
write out explicitly
the Lorenz transformation
matrix lambda.
I gave it in the last lecture.
And I'm assuming you're all
experts in special relativity,
and I don't need
to go over that.
So I will then
using this as sort
of the prototype, the
general notion of a vector
in spacetime, which
we'll often call
a 4-vector for
the obvious reason
that it has 4
components, I'm going
to treat that as any quartet of
numbers that has transformation
properties just like
the displacement factor
I just went over.
So if there's some
quantity A that
has time like an x
or y and z component,
as long as a different
observer, for reasons having
to do with the
underlying physics
or whatever the
heck this A is, as
long as that different observer
relates their components
to observer O's components
via the Lorenz transformation,
you got yourself a 4-vector.
Any random set of four
numbers, that ain't a 4-vector.
You need to have some
physics associated with it.
And the physics has
to tell it that it's
a thing that's related by
a Lorenz transformation.
So I want to pick
up this discussion
by introducing four
particularly important
and special vectors,
which to be honest,
we're not going to use
too much beyond some
of the first couple of
weeks or so of the course,
but they're very useful.
And one should often bear in
mind, even later in the course
when they've sort
of disappeared,
that they're coming along
for the ride secretly.
And these are basis vectors.
So if I go into frame O--
I'm just going to pick some
particular reference frame--
I can immediately write
down four special vectors.
So remember, this is a Cartesian
type of coordinate system.
So I'm going to introduce e0.
I'm going to represent
this by just the number 1
in the time slot and
0 everywhere else.
e1, or ex if you
prefer, I'm going
to write that down like so.
And you can kind of see
where I'm going with this.
The analogy, if you've all seen
unit vectors in other classes,
hopefully this is fairly
obvious what I'm doing.
I'm just picking out
a set of, you know,
little dimensionless simple
quantities that point along
the preferred
directions that I've
set up in this inertial
reference frame.
A compact way of writing this--
so notice, I have
four of these vectors.
And these vectors each
have four components.
And so what I can say is that
the beta component of unit
vector e alpha is
representative,
according to observer O, by
delta alpha beta, the Kronecker
delta.
If you're not familiar
with this one,
I'm usually reluctant to
send you to Wikipedia.
But in this case,
I'm going to send you
to Wikipedia, Wiki
via Kronecker delta.
Yeah, so what that does
is it just emphasizes that
at least in-- by
the way, I should
put little o's underneath all
of these things, because I
have chosen this according to
observer o's representation.
So this is just saying that
a coin to observer O, these
are four very special vectors.
The utility of these things--
up high for everyone in
back to be able to see--
the utility of doing
this is that if I now
want to write the vector
A as a geometric object,
I can combine the components
that observer O uses
with the basis vectors
that observer O uses.
And I can sum them all together.
I can put them together.
And then I've got the--
it's not a representation.
That's a damn vector.
OK?
I put it all together using sort
of an internally consistent set
of numbers and basis vectors.
And so I am free to say
this, where I actually
use an actual equal sign.
You might stop and
think, well, but those
aren't the components of the
observer O bar would use.
And you're right.
Observer O bar would not
use those components.
They would also not use
those basis factors.
We're going to talk about
how those things change.
But observer O bar does agree
that if they were handed
O's components and
O's basis vectors,
this would give me a complete
representation of what
the vector is.
OK?
So again, I'm really
harping on this sort
of distinction between
the geometric object
and the representation.
This is the geometric object.
And we can take
advantage of this.
The fact that that
combination of things
is the geometric object is a
tool that I'm going to now--
is a fact that I'm going
to exploit in order
to figure out how my
basis vectors transform
when I change reference frames.
So let me just repeat
what I wrote of there.
But-- oops-- good point for
just a slight editorial comment.
When you're talking
and writing and there
are millions of little
sub scripts and indices,
sometimes the brain
and the appendages
get out of sync
with one another.
I caught that one.
I don't always.
OK?
So if you see
something like that
and you kind of go, um, why
did that alpha magically turn
into a beta, it's
probably a mistake.
Please call it out.
OK?
All right, so this is how I
build this geometric object,
using the components
and the basis
vectors as measured by
O, as used by observer O.
Let's now write
out what they would
be if they were measured by a
different observer, an O bar
observer.
I know how to get components,
the barred components
from the unbarred components.
I don't yet know how
to get the barred basis
vectors from the
unbarred basis vectors.
But I know that they exist.
And that once I know what they
are, this equation is true.
OK?
These are just
two different ways
of writing this
geometric object, which
every observer agrees
has its existence that
transcends the representation.
So let's rewrite what I've
got on the right-hand side
of the rightmost
equal sign here.
I'm going to write this as
lambda mu bar beta A beta
e mu bar.
And then now I'm going
to use a trick, which
is what the-- it's not
even so much a trick,
but I'm just going to use a
fact that is great when you're
working in index notation.
So often when students
first encounter
this kind of notation,
your instinct
is to try to write
everything out using
matrices and things like row
vectors and column vectors.
It's a natural thing to do.
I urge you to get over that.
If I get some
bandwidth for that,
I'm going to write
up a set of notes
this weekend showing how
one can translate at least 2
by 2 objects--
two index objects
and one index objects
in a consistent way
between matrices and row
vectors and column vectors.
But we're rapidly going to
start getting into objects that
are bigger than that, for
which trying to represent them
in matrix-like form
gets untenable.
In a little while we're going
to have a three index object.
And since we don't have
three-dimensional chalkboards,
making this sort of matrix
representation of that
is challenging.
Soon after that, we'll
have four index objects.
And we'll occasionally
need to take derivatives
of that four index object,
giving us a five index object.
At that point, the ability
to sort of treat them
like matrices is hopeless.
So really, you should
just be thinking
of this as ordinary
multiplication
of the numbers that are
represented by these components
as written out here.
And an ordinary
multiplication like this,
I can just go ahead and swap
the order of multiplication
very easily here.
So what I'm going
to do is move the--
hang on a second.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, now
I see what I'm doing.
Sorry about that.
I misread my notes.
I'm just going to move
the A onto the other side
of my lambda.
And then I'm going
to use the fact
that beta on my right-hand
side is a dummy index.
So in that final expression
I wrote down over there,
beta is a dummy index.
And I'm free to adjust it
to put it into a form that's
more convenient for me.
So let's begin.
Let me just write where I've
got this equation right now
over there.
So A alpha E alpha equals--
and what I've got then is
component A beta lambda mu bar
beta--
keep mu bar.
Sorry about that.
So I'm going to
remap my dummy index.
The reason I did that is I can
now move this to the other side
and factor out the A alpha.
OK, everyone can
see that I hope.
So see what I did
was I arranged this
so that I've
isolated essentially
only the transformation
of the basis vector.
So this equation has
to hold no matter
what vector I am working with.
It's got to hold for
an arbitrary A alpha.
So the only way that
can happen, this
means that my transformation
of basis vectors
obeys a law that
looks like this.
Now, on first
inspection, you're going
to go, ah, that's
exactly what we
got for the components
of the 4-vector.
Caution-- I'm going
to remind you,
it's actually on the
board over there.
OK?
The barred component is
playing a different role
than the barred
basis vector here.
If you want to get
the barred basis
vector from the
unbarred basis vector,
you need to work with the
inverse of this matrix.
That's what this
is telling us here.
OK?
All that being said, if you're
just working through this
and you've got your
components set up
and you're sort of
hacking through it,
the algorithm for you to
follow is actually simple.
Really, all we're doing
is lining up the indices.
We're summing over the
ones that are repeated
and requiring that
those that are
on both the left-hand side
and the right-hand side
appear and equal one another.
Or as an old professor
of mine liked
to say about 12 times a
lecture, line up the indices.
So that's essentially
what we're doing.
In this case, I line up--
if I have my Lorenz
transformation
matrix with the barred index
up top and the unbarred
down below.
Boom, I line up the indices.
And that tells me what the
unbarred basis components
are from the barred ones, and
vice versa for the components.
So what basically, as I
just said, that tells me
if I actually want to get
this guy given this guy,
I need to work with the inverse.
Put this up high so that
everyone in the back
can see it.
So this, again, is one
of those places where
you might be tempted to
sort of write out a matrix
and do a matrix inversion.
But before you do that,
remember this is physics.
OK?
The inverse is going to be-- the
inverse matrix is going to be
the one that does, at least
for certain quantities--
what the Lorenz
transformation does
is that it relates
objects, if I'm at rest,
if I consider myself at rest,
it tells me about things
according to a frame that it's
moving with respect to me.
The inverse matrix
does the opposite.
It would say to
that person being
at rest, what is the
matrix that tells them
about things according
to me, and they
see me moving with the
exact same velocity,
but in the opposite direction.
So to get the inverse matrix,
to get the inverse Lorenz
transformation,
what we end up doing
is we just reverse the velocity.
So I've just wrote
down for you--
and it's worth bearing in mind,
every one of these lambdas
that is there, they
are really functions.
And so my e alpha that
I wrote down over there,
I'm going to use an under
tilde to denote a 3 vector.
In one of your textbooks,
it's written with a boldface.
But that's hard to
do on a blackboard.
So if I want to go
the other direction,
well, I just need to have
the inverse transformation.
And I have that.
Bear in mind, I mean, those are
really the exact same matrices.
OK?
In terms of the function
that I'm working with here,
I'm just flipping around
the direction in order
to get these things out.
OK?
So, as I said, you
might be tempted just
to go ahead and do
the matrix inversion.
Let we just do a
quick calculation
to show you that
that would work.
And the reason I'm
doing this is I
just want to quickly step
through a particular step,
which is, again, sort of in the
spirit of swatting mosquitoes
with sledgehammers, it's
the kind of analysis
that you're going to sort of
have to do off to the side
now and again.
So given that I
know e alpha is--
let's see, let's use beta--
e beta bar be e beta bar.
But I now know that I could
write this guy as lambda--
let's use a gamma--
beta bar minus v in
the gamma direction.
Now, you look at that,
and you go, ooh, look,
I'm actually summing
over the betas there.
Let's gather my terms a
little bit differently.
So notice, I have unbarred basis
vectors over here on the left,
unbarred ones over
here on the right,
a bunch of junk in these
braces here in the middle.
The only way for that to work
is if after summing over beta,
that bunch of junk is, in
matrix language, we'd say,
it's the identity matrix.
In component
notation, we're going
to call it the Kronecker delta.
Just as little
aside, if I started
with the barred on the
left side and the unbarred
in the right-hand side and
did a similar analysis,
it would take you at this point
now that you are all fully
expert in this kind
of index manipulation,
it should take you no
more than about a minute
to demonstrate to yourself
that you can get a Kronecker
delta on the barred
indices in a similar way,
just by using them in a
slightly different order.
OK?
All right, so far all still
basically just formulas.
So I'm going to start now doing
a little bit of formalism that
will very quickly
segue into physics.
We can all take a
deep sigh of relief
and go, ah, OK, something
you can imagine measuring.
So that's nice.
So I have introduced 4-vectors.
I haven't introduced the basis
vectors and their components.
I haven't really done
anything with them yet.
So before we start
doing things with them,
let's think about
some operations
that we can do with 4-vectors.
So the first one which
I'd like to introduce
is a scalar product.
To motivate the scalar
product that I'm
going to define in the same
way that I defined 4-vectors
as a quartet of numbers whose
transformation properties
are based on the transformation
properties of the displacement,
I'm going to motivate
a general scalar
product between 4-vectors by a
similar kind of quantity that
is constructed from
the displacement.
So let me recall a
result that I hope
is familiar from
special relativity.
So working in units where
the speed of light is 1,
you are hopefully all
familiar with the fact
that this quantity
is something that is
in variance to all observers.
I did not use a
represented by symbol
there, because no matter
whose delta t, delta
x, delta y, delta
z I use there, they
will all agree on the delta s
squared that comes out of this.
If I want to--
actually, let me write
of a few things done
before I say anything more.
So this is an invariant.
This is the same--
let me actually write this in a
slightly different way-- it is
the same in all Lorenz frames.
So pick some observer, get their
delta t, delta x, et cetera,
assemble delta s squared,
pick a different observer,
do the Lorenz transformation,
assemble their delta t prime,
delta x prime, et cetera, make
that, boom, they all agree.
So we're going to
use this to say,
you know what, I'm going to
call that the inner product
of the displacement
vector with itself.
So I'm going to call this
delta x dotted into delta x.
And so what this means is that
built into my scalar product--
so if I write this as
a particular observer
would compute it--
this is the scalar
product that I'm
going to define with respect
to the displacement vector.
And this is usually the point
where somebody in the class
is thinking, why is
there a minus sign
in front of the timelike piece?
I can't answer that.
All I can say is
that appears to be--
more than appears to be.
There's a whole frickin' butt
load of evidence-- that's
not how nature is assembled.
OK, it's connected to
the fact-- so the fact
that all of my
spatial directions
are sort of entered
with the same sign,
but my timelike direction,
it has a different sign.
It's connected to the fact
that I can easily move
left and right, front and back.
It's a little bit of effort.
I can move up and down.
But I cannot say, oh, crap, I
left my phone at home I'll go
back 15 minutes and pick it up.
You cannot move back
and forth in time.
Time actually, which is
the timelike component
of this thing, it
enters into the geometry
in a fundamentally different
way from the spatial things.
And that's reflected
in that minus sign.
Anything deeper than
that, let's just
say that we're probably
not likely to get very
far with that conversation.
Depending on what kind
of muscle relaxants
you enjoy using on
the weekend, you
might have some fun
conversations about it.
But it is not something
that you're really
going to get very far with.
You just kind of have
to accept that it's
part of the built-in
geometry of nature.
OK, so this I am defining
as the inner products
of the displacement
vector with itself.
I define vectors as having the
same transformation properties
as the displacement vector.
We can similarly define an
inner product of a 4-vector
with itself.
OK, now, I'll put
this on another board.
So A dot A, I'm going
to define this--
or rather I will say it
is represented according
to observer O as minus A0
squared plus A1 squared plus A2
squared plus A3 squared.
I realize there can be a
little bit of ambiguity
in the way I'm writing it here.
You just have to--
if you're ever confused,
just ask for clarification
about whether I'm writing
something to a power
or whether it's an index label.
Context usually makes it clear.
Handwriting sometimes
obscures context though.
The reason why I'm doing this
and a real benefit of this
is that whatever
this quantity is,
because A has the
same transformation
properties of the
displacement, this must
be a Lorenz invariant as well.
The underlying mathematics
of Lorenz transformation
doesn't care that I wrote a
zero instead of delta x here.
It doesn't care that I wrote A1
instead of delta x1, et cetera.
It just knows that
it's a thing that
goes into that slot of
the Lorenz transformation.
So all observers-- this
is how I represent it
according to observer O. But all
observers agree on that form.
And as a consequence, this
is going to be something
that we exploit a lot.
Even when we move beyond
the simple geometry
of special relativity,
a generalization of this
will be extremely important
for, not an exaggeration to say,
everything.
So a little bit of terminology--
so if A dot A is negative, and
depending upon which is bigger,
A0 squared or the sum
of the other ones--
it could very well be negative--
we say that A is a
time like vector.
This traces back to
the fact that if A
were the displacement
vector, if the displacement,
the invariant interval, were
negative that would tell me
that the two events, which
are the beginning and the end
of the interval, I could
find a frame at which they're
at the exact same location and
are only separated in time.
In the same way,
this is basically
saying that I can
find a frame when
this vector points parallel
to some observer's time axis.
If this is positive,
A is spacelike.
Everything I just said about
timelike, lather, rinse,
repeat, but replace
time with space.
OK?
And if A dot A equals
0, we say A is--
there's two words that
are commonly used--
lightlike or null.
Null just traces back
obviously to the zero.
Lightlike is because this is a
vector that could lie tangent
to the trajectory that a light
beam follows in spacetime.
OK?
OK, let me get some clean chalk.
So, so far, I've only talked
about this inner product,
this scalar product.
Oh, and, by the way, I'll
use inner product and scalar
products somewhat
interchangeably.
But this allows me
to reiterate a point
I made in Tuesday's lecture.
When I say scalar, scalar
refers to a quantity which is--
you know, it doesn't have any
components associated with it.
So in that sense, it's familiar
from your eager intuition of,
you know, not to vector.
But it has a deeper
meaning in this course,
because I also want
it to be something
that is invariant
between reference frames.
So A dot A is the
scalar product.
It gives me a quantity that
all observers agree on.
Now, I've only done
scalar products
of vectors, A and the
displacement vector,
with themselves.
So a more general notion,
if I have vectors A and B,
then I will define the
inner product between them,
as observed by O, as constructed
by observer O, rather, like so.
It's not hard to
convince yourself,
given everything
we've done so far,
that this quantity
must also be invariant.
I'll sketch a
really quick proof.
Let's define-- let's say
we have two 4-vectors, A
and B. Their sum, by
the linearity rules that
apply to these vectors,
must also be a vector.
And so if I compute, C dot
C, this is an invariant.
With a little bit of
labor, that basically
boils down to middle
school algebra.
You can show that C dot
C is A dot A plus B dot B
plus twice A dot B.
This is invariant.
And so this must be invariant.
So this is really useful for
us, because we now have a way--
I've introduced these objects,
these geometric objects,
these 4-vectors.
We are going to use
them in this class
to describe quantities
that are of interest
to the physicist who wants to
make measurements in spacetime.
We've now learned
one of the things
when you're doing
stuff in relativity
is you have to be careful
who is measuring what.
What are the components
that 4-vector as seen
by this observer?
What about their friend who's
jogging through the room at 3/4
quarters speed of light?
What about their friend who's
driving 2/3 the speed of light
in the other direction?
You have all these really
annoying calculations that you
can and sometimes have to do.
This gives us a way to
get certain things that
are invariant out
of the situation
that everyone is
going to agree on.
Invariants are our friends.
So earlier today, earlier
in today's lecture,
I talked about how I can write
my 4-vectors using the basis
factors.
So another way of writing this--
so what's sort of annoying
is every time I've actually
written out the inner product,
I have used the represented
by symbol.
I don't want that.
I want to have equal
symbols in there, dammit.
So let's take advantage
of the fact that A dot B,
I know how to expand A and
B using components and basis
vectors.
And again, using
the index notation,
I can just pull everything
out and rearrange
this a little bit.
Whenever you get down
to a point like this,
we now get to do what every
mathematician loves to do--
give something a name.
I'm going to define the
inner product of basis vector
A with basis vector B to
be a two index tensor--
eta alpha beta.
What's lovely about this, this
is a totally frame invariant
quantity.
We know that.
And so I've now found a way to
write this using the components
as something that gives me
a result that is totally
frame invariant.
Now, when you hack
through a little bit
the algebra of this,
what you'll find
is that the components
of this metric--
oh, shoot, I didn't want to
actually say it out loud--
the components of this
tensor, which pretend
you didn't hear me say that--
the components of this tensor
has the following components--
I just said something circular--
has the following values.
This is, as I
unfortunately gave away
the plot, this is,
in fact, the metric
that I said at the beginning
is the quantity that I must
associate with
spacetime in order
for there to be a notion
of distance between events.
I haven't really said what
a tensor is carefully yet.
I'm going to make a more
formal definition of this
in just a moment.
But this is your
first example of one.
And so the way in
which this actually
gives me a notion of
distance is through this
that I wrote down right here.
If I have two
events in spacetime
that are separated by
a displacement delta x,
the delta s squared, which
I obtained from this thing,
is fundamentally the notion
of distance between those two
events that I use.
And notice, it's a little
less normal of a distance
than you're used
to when you do sort
of ordinary Euclidean geometry.
This is a distance whose
square can be negative.
What we like to say
is that when you're
working in special
relativity, it's
not necessarily positive-- the
distance between two events
is not necessarily-- the
distance squared is not
necessarily positive definite.
If it's negative,
though, that just means
it's sort of dominated by the
time interval between them.
If it's positive, you know
it's dominated by the space
interval between them.
If it's zero, well,
you actually know--
it's actually a little bit
confusing at that point.
They could be, in
fact, you know,
very widely separated
in both space and time,
but in such a way that a
light beam could connect them.
So there's a lot of
information encoded in that.
Now, as we move forward--
hang on a second--
as we move forward, we're
going to upgrade this.
So right now, our metric
is just this simple matrix
of minus 1s, 0s, and 1s.
One of things that
we're going to do
is sort of a warm-up exercise
to the more complicated things
we're going to do
later is we're going
to move away from
special relativity
and Cartesian coordinates.
We're going to look at
it in polar coordinates.
That's going to be kind
of like a warm-up zone.
And so when we do
that, we're always
going to reserve eta for the
metric of special relativity
when I'm working in
Cartesian coordinates.
It's just a great
symbol to have for that.
And it's a useful
thing to always
have that definition in mind.
I can continue to do
special relativity,
but then working in
coordinates that are, you know,
spherical-like or polar-like
or something like that,
then this is going
to become a function.
And what that is
going to mean is
that things like my
little basis vector
is going to have more
complicated behavior.
A little later in the
course, we will then
show that when gravity
enters into the picture,
essentially the
essence of gravity
is going to be encoded in
this thing as well in a way
where, again, it's
going to be a function.
It's going to vary as a
function of space and time.
And the dynamics of gravity
will be buried in that.
It's sort of funny that it
really does just sort of start
out--
I mean, if you take that thing
and you set delta t equals 0,
this is just the bloody
Pythagorean theorem.
That is all this is.
Put time back in, and it
sort of is the generalization
of Pythagoras to spacetime.
And, in fact, we're going
to take advantage of that
and sort of define
a geometry that
looks like this as being
flat in the same way
that a board is flat, and
the Pythagorean theorem works
perfectly on it.
Then, we're going to
start think about what
happens when it becomes curved.
And you start
thinking about things
like, what is the geometry on
the surface of the sphere look
like?
That's just sort
of pointing ahead.
So I just throw that
at you, so that you
get ready for some
of the concepts
that we'll be
talking about soon.
So let me write this actually
in terms of differentials.
It's sort of useful for
what I want to say next.
So a little differential, if
I have two events in spacetime
that are very close
to one another,
I can write them like so.
And what I've
essentially done here
is written dx as
dx alpha e alpha.
Before I get into some
more sort of a couple
of important, fairly
important 4-vectors,
the reason I did this is I
want to make an important point
about some notation and
terminology that is used.
If it is the case that the
displacement vector is related
to the differentials of
your coordinates like so,
we say that e alpha is a
coordinate basis vector.
What it does is it transforms a
differential of your coordinate
into a differential
vector in spacetime.
Now, you, may be thinking
to yourself, OK, well, what
other kind can there be?
Well, this is where
my little spiel there
a second ago about
how we're going
to start looking at
more complicated things,
it's going to become important.
So when we're working in a
Cartesian-like coordinate
system, the fact that this is
what we call a coordinate basis
vector isn't very interesting.
Suppose I was working in
some kind of a curvilinear
coordinate system, OK?
Spherical coordinates.
Now, let's just focus
on 3-space for a second.
So if I write a sort
of analogous equation
in curvilinear coordinates--
OK, so here's the
3-space version of that.
Now let's imagine that i
equals 1 corresponds to radius,
i equals 2 is theta,
i equals 3 is phi.
Then, this would be dr er plus d
theta e theta plus d phi e phi.
Does that disturb you at all?
OK, this has
dimensions of length.
These have the
dimensions of angle.
In order for this to work,
er must be dimensionless.
e theta must have the
dimensions of length.
e phi must have the
This is what a
coordinate basis looks
like when I am dealing with--
well, we're going to use
is a lot in this thing.
I introduce this right now
because you are all probably
looking at that, and
some small part of you
inside is weeping, because
what you want me to write down
is this.
Ah, isn't that better?
OK, this looks like
something you're used to.
So I throw this
out here right now
just because I want
to make sure you're
aware that there
are some equations
and some foundational stuff
you guys have been doing
over the years, particularly,
this shows up a lot when you've
done E&M out of a textbook
like Purcell or Griffiths
or Jackson, because there's
some derivative operators, which
are assuming that your basis
vectors are what we call
orthonormal.
So my e i hat here, it
is an orthonormal basis.
And orthonormal
basis is defined such
that the dot product of any
two members of this thing
gives me back the
chronic or delta.
That is not necessarily
the case when
I work with a coordinate basis.
Our basis has er
dot er equals 1.
Yay, that one's nice.
But when I do e theta dot
e theta, I get r squared.
e phi dot e phi will be r
squared sine squared theta.
And what I'm going
to do when I start
generalizing these things,
I'm going to change my--
this thing which I
defined up here--
do I still have it on the board?
Yeah, yeah, right here.
So when I set eta alpha beta is
e alpha dot e beta and I made
it this thing, I'm going
to generalize this and say
at the dot product
of any two basis
vectors it gives me
a more general notion
of a metric tensor.
And the values in
the metric tensor
maybe functions like this.
Right now, throw that
out there, you know,
this might be sort of just
like a peak of the horrors
that lie ahead.
OK, we're not going to worry
about this too much just yet.
But I want you to be
prepared for this.
In particular,
it's really useful
to have this notion
of a coordinate basis
versus an orthonormal
basis in your head.
We're going to start defining
some derivative operations
soon.
In fact, probably won't
get to them today,
but they will be present when
we start doing Lecture 3.
And there's a couple
of results that come up
where everyone's
sort of like, wait, I
knew that the divergence had a
factor of r on that derivative
there.
Where'd it go?
It's because we're not working
in an orthonormal basis.
All right, I'm a
little sick of math.
So let's do a little physics.
So, so far, the actual
only physical 4-vector
that I've introduced is
the displacement vector.
From the displacement
vector, it's really easy
to make the probably
the first and simplest
important 4-vector, which
is known as the 4-velocity.
This tells me the rate of
displacement of an observer
as this person moves
through spacetime per unit--
and we're going to be careful
about this in this class--
d tau is the time
interval as measured
along the trajectory of the
observer with 4-velocity u.
In other words-- that's a very
long winded way of saying it--
it's an interval of proper time.
In English, the word proper
time sounds very like, woo,
I don't want to
use improper time.
I better use that.
But this actually I think
it comes from French.
It just refers to the fact
that it's one's own time.
Apparently in German
people say eigenzeit.
So, you know, there's a couple
of different words for it.
But proper time is what we use.
In special relativity,
if we see someone
going by with constant velocity,
a particular observer who sees,
you know--
we're here in the room.
Someone comes through.
Their 4-velocity is u.
We would see their 4-velocity
to have the components
gamma gamma v, where
gamma, I'll remind you,
is the special
relativistic Lorenz factor.
And I'll remind you again
we've set speed of light to 1.
A very useful thing,
which we're actually
going to take advantage
of quite a bit,
is that in the rest frame of u--
pardon me for a second--
in the rest frame
of u, or I should
say of the observer
whose 4-velocity is u,
they just have 1 in
atomic direction, C,
if you want to put your
factors back into their.
And that's basically just saying
that the person is standing
still, but moving through
time, because you are always
moving through time.
All right, from the 4-velocity
for an observer who has--
or for an object, I should
say, who has some mass,
we can easily define
the 4-momentum,
where this m is known as the
rest mass of this object.
It's worth a bit of
description here.
You will often see, particularly
in some older textbooks that
discuss special
relativity, people
like to talk about
the relativistic mass.
And that comes from the
fact that if I write out
what this thing
looks like according
to some particular observer,
you have this gamma m entering
into both of the components.
And so older
textbooks often called
gamma m the relativistic mass.
That's not really
the way people have--
over the course of the
past couple decades,
they've moved away from that.
And it's just more useful
to focus on the rest mass
as the only really
meaningful mass,
because, as we'll
see in a moment,
it's a Lorenz invariant.
We'll see how that is in
literally about 3 minutes.
And so what we're
instead going to say
is that as seen by some
particular observer,
this has a timelike
component that
is the energy that that
observer would measure
and a set of
spacelike components
that are the momentum that
that observer will measure.
So where we get a bit of
important physics out of all
this stuff is by coupling these
two 4-vectors to the scalar
products that we made up.
So the first one,
if you do u dot u,
according to any
observer, that's
just going to be
minus gamma squared
plus gamma squared v squared.
And with about 20 seconds
worth of analysis,
you can find that this is
always equal to minus 1.
Actually, there's an even
trickier way to do this.
Suppose I evaluate this in
the rest frame of the observer
whose 4-velocity is u?
Well, in the rest frame,
v is 0, and gamma is 1,
and I get minus 1.
And this is an invariant.
So whatever I get in
that particular frame
must be obtained in all frames.
That's a trick
we're going to use
over and over and over again.
Sometimes you can identify--
you know, you get some kind
of God awful expression
that just makes
you want to vomit.
But then you go,
wait a minute, what
would this look like in
frame blah, blah, blah?
And you sort of think about
some particular frame.
And in that frame,
it may simplify.
And if it does and it's a frame
invariant quantity, mazel tov,
you have just basically
won the lottery.
You've got this
all taken care of.
Go on with your life.
So the 4-velocity has a
scalar product of itself
that is always minus 1.
OK?
How about the 4-momentum?
Well, the 4-momentum is
just 4-velocity times mass.
So that's just minus m squared.
But we also know it's related
to these two other quantities,
which are important in physics.
This is related to the
energy and to the momentum.
So this is also equal to
minus e squared plus--
so this is the ordinary 3--
the magnitude of the 3-vector
part of this thing as
measured by the
observer who breaks up
the 4-momentum in this way.
So what this means is I
can manipulate this guy
around a little bit here.
Anybody who works
in particle physics
is presumably familiar
with this equation.
Sometimes it appears
with the p squared
moved onto the other side.
If it looks a little
bit unfamiliar to you,
let me put some factors
of C back in this.
So remember, we have
set C equal to 1.
When you put it back
in, that's what this is.
So it drops out of this in
a very, very simple way.
One of the uses of this--
and many of you have
done exercises presumably
in some previous
study that does this.
And there'll be one
exercise on the p set
that was just posted
where you exploit this.
So a key bit of
physics, the reason
why we care about 4-momentum is
it's in one mathematical object
allows us to combine
conservation energy
and conservation of momentum.
So conservation of 4-momentum
puts both conservation
of energy and
conservation of momentum
into one mathematical object.
So if I have n
particles that interact,
then the total 4-momentum is
conserved in the interaction.
OK?
So, yeah, we talk a
little bit more about this
and then just sort
of quickly move on.
So combining this
with the fact that we
are free to change our
reference frames often
it gives us a trick that
allows us to really simplify
a lot of analysis.
So if I have n
particles that are
sort of swarming
around and doing
some horrible bit of
business that I need to study
and I need to have a
good understanding of,
we can often vastly
simplify our algebra
by choosing a special and very
convenient frame of reference
in which to do our analysis--
choose the center
of momentum frame.
So this is the time frame
in which that that p tote--
so C-O-M, center of momentum--
has zero spatial momentum.
In that frame, you have just as
much momentum going to the left
as going to the right,
just as much going forward
as going backwards, as much
going up as going down.
And so this turns out to be--
so the classic example of where
this is really useful is when
you are studying particle
collisions and you're looking
at things like the production
of new particles.
So imagine you've got particle
A with some 4-momentum PA coming
in like this.
Particle B's got some
4-momentum coming in like this.
These guys collide.
And they do so--
I work in the center
of momentum frame.
I might want to just calculate
the energy at which they just
happen to produce some new
pair of particles at rest.
I would like to
find the threshold
for this particular
creation process.
OK?
So you're going to
play with one problem
on the p-set that's
kind of like that.
Let's see, what do
I have time to do?
I think I will do--
yeah, I think I can
do two more things.
So all the dot products that I
have been talking about so far
have been a dot product
of a 4-vector with itself.
I did u dotted into u.
I did p dotted into p.
I invented a frame in which p
has a particularly simple form.
And then when you actually
do some of analysis,
you would probably take that
p tote and dot it into itself.
I haven't done
anything that looks
at the crossing between
these two things,
dotting one into the other.
So let me to go through
a very useful result that
follows by combining p with u.
There's a very
specific notion of p
and a very specific notion of u.
Let's let p be the
4-momentum of a particle.
I call it a.
Let's let u be the 4-velocity
not of a, but the 4-velocity
of observer O. So
particle a might
be a muon that was created
the upper atmosphere
and is crashing through
our room right now.
Observer O might be
your hyperactive friend
who is jogging through the room
at half the speed of light.
The question I want to ask
is, what does O measure
as the energy of particle a.
So the naive way to do
this, which I will emphasize
is not wrong, what you
might do is sort of go,
OK, well, we're sitting here.
This room is our laboratory.
I've measure this
thing in my lab.
So I know p as I measure it.
I can see O jogging by.
So I know O's 4-velocity
as I measure it.
So what I should do is figure
out the Lorenz transformation
that takes me into
the rest frame of O.
Once I have that
Lorenz transformation,
I'll apply that
Lorenz transformation
to the 4-vector p.
Boom, that will
give me that energy.
That will work.
That will absolutely work.
But there's an
easier way to do it.
So one thing you should note is
that everybody represents that
4-velocity as an energy--
excuse me, they
represent the 4-momentum
as an energy and a 3-momentum.
In particular, though,
they represent it
as the energy that
they would measure
and the 3-momentum that
they would measure.
So that means p as seen
by O is e according to O
and p according to O. That are
acquainted o is what we want.
And I just told
you a moment ago,
you know, if you have p in
your own reference frame,
and you have u in your
own reference frame,
you can do this whole math
with Lorenz transformations
and get it out.
But you also know that in
O's own reference frame,
O represents their 4-velocity as
1 in the timelike direction, 0
in the spatial direction.
So what this means is if I
go into O's reference frame,
if I go into their
inertial reference frame,
notice that if I take the
dot product of p and u,
I get e times 1 and p times 0.
So that is just negative.
It's exactly what I
want-- modulo minus sign.
And so you go, OK, well, I'll
flip my minus sign around.
And you think, OK,
great, but I did
that using those
quantities as written down
in O's reference frame.
And then you go,
holy crap, that's
the invariant scalar product.
I'm done.
Mic drop.
Leave the room.
What this means is you start
with p as you measure it,
u as you measure it.
Take the scalar product
between the two of them.
Boom, the answer
you want pops out.
No nonsense of Lorenz
transformations.
None of that garbage
needs to happen.
You just take that inner
product and you've got it.
So that sort of says
in words, no matter
what representation you choose
to write down p and u in,
take the dot product
between the two of them,
throw in a minus sign, you've
got the energy of the particle
with p as measured by
the observer with u.
It's sort of late in the
hour, or the hour and a half
I should say.
So let me just
sort of emphasize,
there are occasional
moments in this class where
if you're dozing off a little
bit, I suggest you pop up
and tattoo this into
a neuron somewhere.
This is one of those moments.
OK?
This is a result that we're
going to use over and over
and over again,
because this holds--
this isn't just in
special relativity.
When we start talking about
the behavior of things
near black holes,
there's going to a place
where I basically at
that point to say,
well, I'm going to use the
fact that the observer measures
an energy that is given by-- and
I'm going to write down that.
The dot product that's
involved is a little bit more
complicated, because
my metric is hairier.
But it's the exact
same physical concept.
OK?
Let me just do one more.
And then I'll go talk,
without getting into the math,
about what I will
start with on Tuesday.
Last 4-velocity, which
is probably useful for us
to quickly talk about is--
so we've talked a
lot about 4-velocity.
That is just one
piece-- when we're
talking about sort of the
kinematics of bodies moving
in spacetime, you need more
information than just velocity.
Sometimes things
are moving around.
There's additional
forces acting on them.
And so we also care
about the 4-acceleration.
And so this is what
I get when I take
the derivative with respect to
proper time of the 4-velocity.
So will there be some homework
exercises that use this.
The main thing which I want to
emphasize to sort of conclude
our calculations for
today is that when
I talk about a 4-velocity
of acceleration,
this has an extremely
important property.
It is always the case that
a dotted into u equals 0.
If you're used to sort of
3-dimensional intuition,
that may seem weird.
OK?
Anytime you see a car
accelerate from a stop, that's
a case in which its
acceleration is clearly not
orthogonal to its velocity.
But the issue here is, this
is not a spatial dot product.
This is a space
time dot product.
And some of your intuition
has to go out the window
because of that.
It's very simple to prove this.
Remember, u dot
u equals minus 1.
So d of u dot u, d
tau, which is just 2, u
dot a is the derivative
of minus 1, which is 0.
OK?
So this is something
that we will exploit.
If you want to describe
the relativistic kinetics
of an accelerating body,
this is a great thing
that we can use to exploit.
You often need a little
bit more information.
We have to give you as a bit
of additional information
some knowledge about what the
orientation of the acceleration
is and things like that.
So whenever you are given--
I'll get to you in just
a sec-- whenever you're
given any kind of differential
quantity like this,
it's not enough to know-- it's
like the acceleration of loss,
you have to also have
boundary conditions.
And that sort of tells you
what the initial direction is.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is that time
still the proper time?
SCOTT HUGHES: That time
is the proper time, yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's
not accelerating?
SCOTT HUGHES: That's right.
So you can still define a
proper time for an accelerating
observer.
It will not relate--
hold that thought.
You're going to play
this a little bit more
in a future problem set.
I mean, the key thing
is that the way--
if you have an d observer,
an interval of proper time
as compared to an interval of
time for, you know, someone
in a rest frame that sees
this person accelerate away,
the conversion between
the intervals of time,
the two measure, it evolves.
So, you know, let's say
you're in this room with me.
In fact, it turns out
that if you accelerate
at 1G for a year,
you get to very
close to the speed of light.
So let's say that you
were in a rocket ship
right now that launched with an
acceleration of G. Initially,
you and I synchronize
our watches.
And so an interval
of a second to me
is the same as a second to you.
Half a year later, you're
moving at something
like half the speed of light.
And I will see a
noticeable time delay.
An interval of a second
as you measure it
looks long compared to me.
Six months later,
you're actually
quite close to the
speed of light,
and it gets dilated even more.
So last thing, which
I'm going to say,
and I'm not going to get into
too much detail with this yet,
is we're going to begin
next time by making
a little bit more formal some
of the notions that go around.
So we've increased some
physics and some vectors.
I've given you guys one tensor
so far, the metric tensor.
And so I'm going to
give you-- in fact,
I will write down a very precise
definition of this right now,
and we'll pick it up
from there on Tuesday.
So the basic idea--
so you guys have see--
the one tensor you've seen
so far is the metric tensor.
And what the metric is is it's
sort of a mathematical object
that I put in a
pair of 4-vectors.
And it spits out a quantity
that is a Lorenz invariant
scalar that characterizes
what we call the inner product
of those two 4-vectors.
More generally,
I'm going to define
a tensor of type 0 N as a
function or mapping of N
4-vectors into Lorenz invariant
scalars, which is linear
in each of its N arguments.
So I will pick it
up here on Tuesday.
And let me just say in words,
the metric is a 0 2 tensor.
I put in two 4-vectors.
It spits out a Lorenz
invariant scalar.
We're going to before
too long come up
with a couple of things that
involve three real vectors--
excuse me three 4-vectors,
too many numbers here,
a trio of 4-vectors, which it
then maps to a Lorenz invariant
scalar.
Some of them will
take in four 4-vectors
and produce a Lorenz
invariant scalar.
Notice I wrote this
in sort of funny way.
The 0 N sort of begs for
there to be sort of an N 0.
OK?
To do that I have to
introduce an object that
is sort of dual to a vector.
We're going to talk about that.
Those are objects
called one-forms,
which actually happen to
be a species of vector.
We're actually going to then
learn that the vector is itself
a tensor.
And so we will make a very
general classification
of these things.
And we'll see that vectors are
just a subset of these tensors.
And at last, we'll sort of have
all the mathematics in place.
We can sort of lose some
of these distinctions
and just life goes on,
and we can start actually
doing some physics with these.
All right, I will pick
it up there on Tuesday.